because you've done some extreme dating
i love the idea of
your your edinburgh show so explain the
the thing that went on in your admission
yeah so i
wrote an edinburgh show i think it was
like 2011 and it was basically about
dating but at the end of every show i
would ask
someone out in the audience or i would
basically get their mates to sort of
volunteer them
because no one ever volunteered
themselves it was always like yeah you
go and like push them
you know everyone else stepped back so
yeah i ended up in some quite
interesting situations because you
actually went on a date
yeah i went on the dance afterwards so
yeah 100 did it
like well with people watching out for
me
um i also had like a fake gin and tonic
that i would
yes this alcohol yummy isn't it just
tonic water
but um yeah there was like a couple of
guys that were well there was one guy
who was lovely but he had he's grown up
he had grown up children so it's just
like i'm gonna be your new mummy
the very first guy i went on this date
with he just looked absolutely terrified
and i took a selfie of us and he's just
like that in a selfie like
he's this french guy and i'm feeling
like i i don't know if he knows what's
going on here
like i don't know if he knows he's on a
date with me and were there any
second dates i'm gonna shock you no
there were no second dates after a month
of edinburgh i know can you believe that
a lot of sex okay
but with the date so
sometimes it ended no that didn't happen
mum that didn't happen
swings and roundabouts kind of oh
there's some swings